super powers awkward kissing and even
more awkward dancing that I'm definitely
not okay with I'm not okay with this as
Netflix's latest coming-of-age superhero
drama from the guys that brought you the
end of the [ __ ] world and in this
video we'll be taking a dive so deep
into the ending it just might make your
head explode before we begin make sure
to LIKE and subscribe and stick around
till the end of the video as we'll be
going over some season 2 theories so
let's jump into it like every episode of
the season we begin with our protagonist
Sydney doing a voiceover of one of her
diary entries after the death of her
father her guidance counselor thought it
would be a good idea for her to write
about her feelings little do we know
that this diary will become the catalyst
for that explosive ending it's also a
great way to glean insight into her
character we get to hear what she's
thinking and how she perceives the world
in Episode one she tells us about her
lot in life that she feels not so
special I'm a boring seventeen year old
white girl I'm not special that's what
I'm trying to say as we'll find out
later this couldn't be further from the
truth
Sydney isn't her usual self at the
beginning of the final episode she's
upbeat positive and even makes her
brother Liam breakfast in packs his
lunch could trash this to the Sydney
earlier in the season who'd make his
brother mustard sandwiches and was so
apathetic making meals that Liam has to
make his famous delicious loaded lasagna
this shift is due in part to her
discovery that her father was just like
her he experienced something within him
he couldn't control like her he felt
like something was following him
eventually it was too much and he
committed suicide or at least that's
what we've been led to believe he had
something in him something that he was
always wrestling with good thing
one Sidney believes that if she could
just find some answers about what's
happening to her maybe things will go
back to normal if I could just find some
answers
maybe maybe things would just go back to
normal so she ventures to the one place
she hates going the basement the place
where her father died she finds a
lockbox and uses her telekinetic powers
to open it up revealing a military
uniform medal and dog tags her mother
finds her there and tells her how things
weren't the same since he came back from
the war apparently he was caught in a
giant explosion which killed not only
the enemy but those on his side as well
leading Sydney to believe this was no
ordinary explosion it was the result of
his uncontrolled powers which she has
now inherited with this new information
Sydney believes she now has two choices
lock up her feelings like her dad did or
make pancakes
what Sydney fails to recognize here is
that she too is walking away from her
problem instead of confronting it just
in a different way and this will come
back to haunt her and bonus points if
you recognize that this was the first
time we see the title card with the word
not struck through notice also that
Sydney has decided to wear her father's
dog tags the same dog tags we saw her
wearing while all bloodied in episode 1
a foreshadowing of things to come it's
her way of remembering him but also
reminding her that when it feels like
she's about to lose control to just not
give a [ __ ]
you'll also notice that everyone at
school is preparing for the homecoming
dance the event that's been hinted at
since episode one can you believe some
people are already asking tates to
homecoming during gym class
Sydney apologizes to her best friend
Deena about the events that transpired
in the library in episode 5 Sydney
recruits Tina to help get the security
footage from the library but lies to her
as to the reason Sydney says it's
because the security tape will show her
having sex with Stanley he's 69 and
everything but the real reason is that
it would show her powers something only
Stanley so far knows about and then this
random Abercrombie model ass Adina out
after word gets around about her breakup
with Brad he's actually the third one
today to ask her out but as Deena says
guys right now
- Deena and Sydney are best friends but
as we've seen throughout the season
Sydney's feelings are a little bit more
than friends this show isn't just about
a young woman struggling to come to
terms with her powers it's also her
coming to terms with her own sexuality
she writes in her diary her confusion
about not liking Stanley saying tell
Stan I don't like him in that way why
don't I it isn't until after she kisses
Sydney that she realizes she's into
women and Deena even hinted this earlier
in the episode saying who seriously
never talk about boys the two are once
again friends with Deena even asking
Sydney out to the dance since both have
dropped their dates we get this montage
of Sydney Deena and Stanley getting
ready and this lovely one of Stanley
pudding body spray on his crotch cuz he
never know what might happen at
homecoming his emotionally abusive
father makes fun of him but Stanley
stands up for himself and that's one of
the things I like about his character
although he may be a bit eccentric when
it comes to his friends he's there for
them even at the end when Brad is
embarrassing Sydney in front of the
entire school
Stanley steps in and is promptly punched
in the face even though he got his butt
kicked he still stood up to the jock who
is way stronger than him and that takes
a lot of courage there's also some major
foreshadowing in this short scene
between Brad and Ricky were Brad chugs a
beer and says just say that today it's
gonna be [ __ ] mind-blowing that's for
sure
Sydney's mother and her have their first
real mother-daughter moment of the
entire season the majority of the
episodes have seen them at each other's
throats
Sydney resents her mother working all
the time even saying about Liam which
hurts her mother deeply she fires Mac
saying he's been gone for almost a year
and you're still choosing him it's nice
to see these two finally patching things
up meanwhile Liam works on a puzzle
which you may remember as being the
thing he and his father used to do
together it's kind of interesting
because he jokingly becomes the father
like figure in this scene telling Deena
to keep Sydney safe and to have her home
on time
Stanley's homecoming date isn't going as
well as it should
this is Mercedes who gets creeped out
when he asked about thighs it's and
starts smoking a joint these were two
things that made his relationship with
Sydney special he's still in love with
her
but Sydney can't help who she is and
what she feels when Stanley gets
rejected by his date at the dance she
goes over and tries to cheer him up
referring to how the school is like a
theatre something Stanley did to her at
the football game she tells him the
truth here that she likes him but just
not in that way and it'll be a few
moments later when Stanley will realize
why when Brad out sir
well Stanley goes over to the DJ to play
some blood which which by the way is not
a real band Dina and Sydney dance when
Dina asked Sydney about that kiss way
back in episode 3 up until this point
they've just kind of awkwardly not
addressed it but Dina now says she
didn't not like it and before Sydney can
respond they're cut off for the
announcement of the homecoming king and
queen which is in turn interrupted by a
drunk Brad who's been crushing beers in
the back of his truck brad has Sydney's
diary the one thing that contains her
deepest darkest secrets her daddy issues
superpowers and love for Sydney he's so
pissed that Sydney discovered his affair
with Jenny and ruined his relationship
with Dina that he's out for blood
it's too bad the only blood that will be
spilled tonight will be his and just as
he's about to reveal her biggest secret
her powers his head completely explodes
I also just love the reactions of the
students in the back especially call me
Carson over here this is when we go
full-on Carrie mode well not exactly I
like to think I'm not okay with this is
like you Carrie if she got laid the
entire auditorium panics and runs away
and so too does Sydney completely
shocked at what just transpired we
aren't talking about accidentally
killing hedgehogs anymore this was a
real person Stan Lee who is still on the
ground recovering from getting punched
notices the body but also locks eyes on
the diary this is likely laying the
foundation for season two with him
picking up the diary and potentially
reading it he'll learn the real reason
why Sydney never really liked him in
that way Stan Lee is also the only
person that knows Sydney has powers
remember Brad was killed just before he
revealed her big secret so going into
season two it's still only Stan Lee who
knows about her powers Deena well we
don't see much of her just that she's
shell-shocked and hovers over the body
of Brad she still doesn't know about
Sydney's powers so it'll be interesting
to see how that manifests next season
and whether or not Sydney telling her
about the powers will get in the way
their potential relationship Sydney runs
down the street as cops rushed towards
the school but she's going somewhere no
one can find her a place mentioned way
back in episode one the abandoned
Watchtower where stanley said a hundred
men died building it she tells us that
she didn't mean to kill Brad and that
maybe she'll just run away and hide
someplace where no one can find her and
for the first time she now knows how her
dad truly felt to live with that guilt
of killing another it's terribly
lonesome and the episode ends with the
appearance of the mysterious figure
who's been following Sydney throughout
the season we first see him in episode 4
keeping tabs on her he's also the one
responsible for the incident in the
library but who is he now I haven't read
the comics the show is based off so I'm
going off my own gut here but I'm
guessing one of two things it could be
her dad who having the same powers as
her has come back since he's seen her
powers manifest how he came back well
when you're a superhero who can appear
out of thin air coming back to life
doesn't seem like much of a stretch but
what I actually think is it could be
someone else entirely the future mentor
or wise sage as Stan Lee put it in
episode 4 while Stan Lee and Sid tried
to figure out her powers Stan Lee asked
if she's been visited by a mentor or
wise old sage who will help her learn
her powers this is likely that guy which
means it could be the father or someone
else entirely but I happen to think it's
not the dad since it doesn't seem she
recognizes him also this character seems
pretty nefarious when Sidney asked if
she should be afraid he responds with
they should be afraid if I'd hazard a
guess it looks like Sidney's powers will
be more of a focus next season as
outside forces will either pull her into
using them for good or for evil overall
this show really took me by surprise
with its mix of teenage drama and
superhero elements if you liked the show
you might also want to check out
Ragnarok which I also did a video on
please consider giving this one a like
and subscribing I'm always coming out
with new content you can also follow me
on twitter at things story whitey until
next time remember we 69 and